Last week,
we ended with the Boston massacre in 1770 and I mentioned at the very end of the
lecture,
the ways in which both onlookers and the British government and the colonists
ended up wondering each one if the other one was somehow engaged in a plot.
Right.
And I mentioned that the British were perhaps wondering if this had all been a
plot to rob the customs house.
The colonists were wondering about the possibility of this being some kind of
ongoing plot to subdue and repress the American colonists.
So clearly at the end of the lecture from last week,
you can really begin to sense a growing sense of mounting hostility,
even among some people,
a sense of growing alienation.
And you can hear this on both sides coming from the accounts of the Boston
massacre by both gauge and Adams.
And I read from them last week.
Um,
and I did mention in class when I read from them that they were of course
writing with a purpose in mind.
So they were interested in being particularly bold and dramatic and what they
were saying gauge really had to excuse what happened in Adams,
was trying to promote people to get upset about what had happened.
Um,
but even so you can hear even just in the way that they framed their accounts,
some of what I'm talking about here with growing hostility,
growing alienation.
So for example,
gauge at the very start of the letter that I read from in the last lecture tells
the person he's writing to that he's writing this letter to inform the king's
ministry quote of the critical situation of the troops and the hatred of the
people towards them.
That's how he starts his letter,
which is really interesting.
So to gauge clearly what he's stating in this letter to his people back home in
the king's ministry is that it doesn't really even feel safe for British
soldiers on the streets of Boston.
The people here hate us.
And Adams also emphasizes this kind of growing alienation and animosity.
And in his case,
he does it in a particularly strong way in a series of newspaper articles for
the Boston Gazette that he wrote a few months after the massacre.
So Adams writes,
I appealed to the common sense of mankind to what a state of misery and infamy
must have people be reduced to have a governor by the soul appointment of the
crown under the absolute control of a week and arbitrary minister to who's
dictates he has to yield an unlimited obedience or forfeit his political career
while he used to be supported at the expense of the people by virtue of an
authority claimed by strangers.
And that's really an interesting statement.
Strangers,
he's referring to parliament,
right?
It's these strangers who are telling these officials what to do.
That's again,
a striking word,
a striking statement.
Now of course here,
Adam says that really striking thing and then he's careful to add right after it
that quote,
um,
for opposing a threatened tyranny,
we have been not only called,
but in effect a judged rebels and traders to the best of kings.
Okay?
He's making a really important distinction there.
He's saying,
yes,
maybe we're upset at what parliament is doing.
Maybe parliament is behaving like a group of strangers,
but we are still good British subjects and we are loyal to our king to the best
of kings.
And it's an important point that even in the midst of all of this animosity and
all of these misunderstandings troops are in Boston streets and the colonists
obviously still feel like British subjects who are loyal to their king and who
are objecting because their rights as British subjects are being violated.
That's the logic that we're working on here and you can see this in Adams Samuel
Adams actions.
At the same time that he's writing all these sort of propaganda newspaper
accounts and trying to stir up animosity.
He also was writing letters to people in England trying to persuade them and
hopefully inspire them to persuade others that the people of Boston were
rightfully defending their liberties and deserve to be defended by people in
parliament,
not condemned and punished.
Equally important,
the colonists,
we're not saying that they wanted nothing to do with parliament or even that
parliament had no authority over the colonies.
Even though the occasional bold statements sort of runs out on an edge and says,
uh,
parliament,
most colonists thought that the colonists,
the colonies were subordinate to parliament in some way.
The problem Massachusetts Governor Thomas Hutchinson,
later remarked is that subordination,
quote was a word without any precise meaning to it.
Okay,
that's a really insightful comment.
Yeah.
Okay.
Colonies or subordinate.
But what does that mean?
And obviously what we're looking at now is a sort of non debate debate in which
it's clear people have different understandings of exactly what the imperial
system is supposed to look like and how it functions.
So all in all,
it's important to remember here that even with all of this friction that we're
seeing between colonists and the British,
the colonists are still loyal British subjects who want the imperial system to
function happily again.
And this is a really great example of why it's always important.
And I think it's particularly important when studying anything in the founding
era,
but I think history generally,
but when studying the revolution or the founding era,
but it was setting the revolution,
it's important not to jump onto the independence bandwagon too quickly and
assume that a separation is inevitable because the people that were studying did
not assume that it's so easy for us to assume that cause we know what's coming.
But remember Freeman's top tips for studying the revolution,
right?
Contingency.
Our historical subjects didn't know what was going to happen and anything could
have happened.
So from our perspective,
we're looking at the events here.
We almost can't help it,
I think on all of our parts.
Even on my part,
it all looks like a ticking clock.
Like there's an inevitable pulling away from the British.
And everything I talk about here represents one step closer to independence and
another step closer to independence.
And part of what I'm trying to say here is clearly that's not how the colonists
or the British at this point are thinking.
That's not how they understand their actions.
That's not how they understand what's happening.
The colonists at this point are not trying to rebel,
and they're not trying to retreat away from the British empire.
They're trying to fix things or trying to figure out how to fix things.
So in a sense,
the best way to understand the events of the first half of the 17th seventies is
to look at the whole revolutionary era without thinking about the revolution.
And by that I mean the war,
just forget that there's going to be a war.
The war doesn't exist.
I always,
as a historian,
I do this to myself when I'm sitting down to write something,
like if I'm writing a project,
I'm working on a book now that takes me up to the civil war.
So I have to constantly say civil war,
I don't know if there's a civil war that's at war because my subjects aren't
assuming until the very late point that there might be one.
And I'm sort of saying the same thing here,
that it's useful to just sort of put the assumption that there's going to be a
war over here and watch the logic of events as they unfold.
It's,
it's a good reminder,
I think for the study of history generally because part of what you're trying to
do as historians is understand what your historical subjects are thinking and
why they're thinking that way.
And you make that much harder when you stick the outcome right in front of them
and compare what they're doing with what you assume to be an inevitable outcome.
Okay.
Now,
I mentioned last time that one way in which the colonists responded to the towns
and acts was to propose boycotting British goods again,
as they had before in their minds successfully with the stamp act.
So now feeling even more threatened,
the colonist didn't simply urge a boycott in an informal way.
Now they actually organize.
So remember there's a pattern I pointed out in an earlier lecture,
um,
when I was talking about previous attempts that colonial union and I mentioned
in that lecture that one of the main things that really drives the colonies to
join together in an effort is some kind of a threat.
So basically self defense is a really good motivator.
And so typically in the past,
something with threatened the colonies intercolonial unity suddenly seemed
important.
There'd be some kind of a movement to do something together for the moment.
And then when the crisis passed the unity past as well.
So we're sort of seeing some of that going into operation here way down the
road,
four Americans,
one of the big lessons of the revolution would ultimately be how powerful it is
when you combine and organize an associate when you form associations or
organizations.
And as we'll begin to see soon when people organize into small coordinated
groups,
they can have an enormous impact.
And that's essentially what happens here in the course of the American
revolution.
So between 1768 and 1770 as they begin to contemplate boycotting British goods,
yet again,
people begin to form non importation associations.
Okay.
Non Importation Associations.
Now these associations,
these organizations,
in a sense we're extra constitutional so they're springing up from outside of
the formal political system,
but in a variety of different ways.
They actually had some real power in the north merchants were at the core of
this movement,
this non Importation Association movement,
although it was grounded on popular support,
but merchants were really at the center of it because one key to the success of
this whole endeavor was for merchants to join together in promising not to
import British goods.
And sometimes merchants actually signed written agreements that they would not
So unity among the merchants could be a powerful thing and in the north that
operated pretty effectively.
So for example,
when,
I swear I'm really not like inserting Rhode Island into every moment in which a
random bad thing happens.
Today we have like two,
at least two.
We have several Rhode Island woman's and every time I come across one I think is
it just cause I'm,
I'm aware of Rhode Island is because I'm thinking about Rhode Island.
Rhode Island appears to be there so much that it makes me think of,
um,
I got my undergraduate degree at Pomona College in California and Pomona has a
thing about the number 47,
which they think appears everywhere,
right?
Everything is 47.
So when you go to Pomona,
it's like the magic of 47 constantly being talked about.
You add letters up to various things and had always equals Ooh,
47 and then people graduated from Pomona and go on to become film writers.
And then you'll see these 40 sevens,
like everyone's like,
there's another one in star wars,
it's a 47.
Um,
so,
so 47 was like the Pomona thing.
And after a while you begin to think,
well,
if I'm looking for 40 sevens,
I'm always going to find 40 sevens.
So today I actually,
when I was writing this,
I thought maybe I'm doing that to Rhode Island and I hope not.
But here's the Rhode Island moment.
Okay.
What's an actual Rhode Island moment?
Um,
some Rhode Island merchants threatened to pull out of the non importation
agreement because it's proving to be troublesome in a variety of ways.
So when these Rhode Island merchants threatened this merchants in Boston and New
York and Philadelphia actually imposed a boycott on Newport and Providence,
Rhode Island,
right,
okay.
There's the power of association.
Oh,
you couldn't think you're going to import British goods.
Okay,
we boycott you Rhode Island,
you're now going to be boycotted.
That's pretty powerful.
So merchants were key here as was the public.
So for example,
in various places in the north colonial legislature's,
sometimes passed resolutions commending these non importation associations to
the people at the people are vital to so you have colonial legislature's passing
resolutions to the public saying you know this whole association never hear as
good and you should really listen to it.
Basically lending legitimacy to what we're essentially really ad hoc
organization's ad hoc committees now in the south the non importation
associations were more centered on the populace,
not quite as centered on merchants.
So southern non importation associations were often very careful to have members
sign on from throughout the community.
So not just merchants but artisans and planters.
And because in the south they were more popularly based,
they were more centered on non consumption than on non importation.
But of course you know you're looking at the north,
which is all about sea ports and importing goods.
It makes sense that in the south maybe there'd be more of a focus on not
consuming imported British goods.
The poster not importing British goods.
Now,
as suggested in the comments that I just made about northern legislatures
supporting northern not importation associations,
it's important to note that these are not rebellious groups acting against the
structure of colonial government.
They're not competing with colonial assemblies.
Their actually in some ways acting in harmony with them.
And as a matter of fact,
some people who were in these bond importation associations probably were in the
colonial legislature is too.
So we're not talking about opposing efforts.
We're talking about sort of parallel efforts that sometimes intersect.
Okay.
So as organizations linking the will of the people with politicized action,
these associations are pretty significant because I'm sure you can see now,
but just based on my description of them,
they're really promoting broad,
popular,
organized,
coordinated,
politicized action.
And this model is going to become more and more significant as the revolution
continues on
and broadly based as they were.
These associations really did help to spread a sense of popular involvement in
resistance to British policy.
Boycotting British goods was a political act and everyone from all levels of
society,
including women,
could be involved in this in some way.
It's spreading a real sense of popular involvement in acts of resistance to
these seemingly unfair acts of parliament.
So average people,
we're not just talking legislators and political radicals like Samuel Adams,
but average people had a sense of involvement in a larger cause and newspaper
articles and broadsides helped spread this sense of involvement,
urging the colonists to avoid luxuries like imported silks or English rum.
And instead people should be virtuous and they should wear homespun clothing
made of cloth that could be made in the colonies and they should drink whiskey
and beer and cider that could be made in the colonies.
Now you'll notice things to drink,
include whiskey,
beer and cider,
but you'll notice water isn't included in that list.
Um,
and actually it wasn't considered a normal beverage at this point in time,
which I always thought was an interesting fact.
And when I was in Grad School,
I read this really interesting British novel written in 1796 has a very strange
title.
The title is herms sprung or man as he is not,
there are a lot of novels at the time called man as he is,
is not.
Um,
but what herms wrong,
it's about,
among other things is the central character is this American in England and he's
the sort of exotic,
strange independent minded creature.
And two things that he does that are sort of shocking,
lead bizarre to all of the British onlookers and this novel is he walks places
instead of riding in a carriage.
Oh my gosh.
She got up this morning from the tavern and went walking.
And then the second even more horrifying thing is he drinks water.
I drank water,
he had a normal dinner,
he drank water.
And there's a weird scene in it in which someone says,
you know,
I can't even describe to you at water.
Tastes like,
why do you drink it?
I mean,
water has no taste.
Water tastes like,
you know,
Herms Francaise water,
water tastes like water.
And it was kind of radical.
So I'm being very patriotic here.
Drink whiskey,
beer and cider period.
Don't worry about that boring water stuff.
It's fascinating that that's considered a weird thing at the time.
Okay.
So people are encouraged to drink and wear only colonial made goods.
And this was true all over the place.
So as I symbolic gesture,
Harvard students gave up drinking tea students at the College of New Jersey.
Now Princeton were homespun clothing and students at Yale,
he says about Yale renounced imported wines.
I actually went and double check that.
I was like,
really?
Yeah,
Yale.
Okay.
Um,
South Carolina assemblymen renounced the wearing of wigs and stockings,
which must've looked very odd with the result.
One observer noted that a foreign visitor arriving Charleston quote would
probably from their dress take them for so many unhappy person's ready for
execution.
Who'd come to petition for,
pardon?
I have all these people with no wigs and know,
like kind of dressed really badly and like hanging out in the legislature.
Okay.
So clearly based on those examples,
even Yale Students,
um,
non portable than maybe I don't know what the,
not having imported wine,
um,
not importation does represent one way in which many people.
And as I said before,
including women became directly involved in colonial protest efforts,
but women were often the primary purchasers of goods.
So their actions were central on this front.
They had to be appealed through.
They had to be included.
So not importation politicize the daily activities of women as well as men
spreading feelings of community level patriotism with people joined in a joint
political effort to defend their rights.
So you have people who are sort of joined and this effort,
it patriotic austerity.
They're all sort of joining and a willingness to sacrifice luxuries for a worthy
cause.
And of course,
not every American,
not every communist is doing this.
So when I say joined,
everyone's joined,
maybe not everyone,
but there are a lot of people who are paying attention to this idea of non
importation.
But of course now that I've made not importation sounds so impressive.
Um,
I will add that it ultimately it was not a roaring success.
because as I just hinted a minute ago,
not everyone really found it very easy to surrender English luxuries.
And as always,
there was a lot of smuggling,
so it wasn't an amazing roaring success.
But that said,
there was some impact on British manufacturers and there was some recognition
that considering the relatively small amount of revenue being raised by the
towns and acts,
maybe the effort wasn't worth all of the trouble.
So some onlookers in Britain began to regret the Townsend acts.
And it's important to note even members of parliament who were sympathetic to
the colonies and who wanted the towns and acts repealed,
even these sympathetic members didn't question the right of parliament to tax
the colonies.
They may have felt that parliament was behaving too aggressively or unwisely.
Maybe it's an unwise policy,
but even people who were considered themselves sort of supporters,
real dire supporters of the American colonists even they were not questioning
the constitutional supremacy of parliament to tax the British colonies.
That's almost like a line in the sand.
So along these lines,
despite the fact that you have some people in parliament who were sympathetic
towards the colonies,
parliament could not just back down and take all of the towns and acts back.
And there are two main reasons for that.
There's such power when you say that there are two reasons and a hundred people
go dunk satisfaction,
no taking.
Um,
but there are two main reasons.
First and most obvious parliament just didn't want to lose face,
right?
They felt that they truly were upholding the supremacy and sovereignty of the
British parliament.
Second,
related to that,
and perhaps more important as far as our understanding of different to evolving
mindsets is concerned,
the sovereignty of parliament over the colonies by this point had become
inextricably bound up with the right of taxing Americans.
And I'll repeat that again.
By this point,
the sovereignty of parliament over the colonies had become inextricably bound up
with the right of taxing American colonists.
So at this point,
parliament couldn't back down on a tax without seeming to give up their
sovereignty over the colonies by 1770.
The right of taxation was not just a means of producing revenue for the British,
but it actually had become an assertion of British sovereignty over its own
colonies.
Okay,
so now we're in 1770 and surprise,
surprise.
By this time we have a new prime minister.
Lord north is now Prime Minister Townsend is gone,
although sort of in a period of revolving doors of prime ministers.
But in this case,
towns and tie downs,
it actually died back in 1767.
And so lord north is the next person who comes along.
Townsend's acts live on without him for a little while.
Um,
but now lord north is the prime minister.
So he assumes this position and with familiar logic,
he decides that the only way to withdraw the towns and acts,
it's going to be to leave behind a token tax in the colonies to prove that
England reigned supreme over its colonial properties as Lord North himself.
Put it.
If I thought I could appease that factions and disobedient temper,
which prevails in the colonies,
I should be glad to do it.
And yet to these people who ought to be our subjects.
We are to make concessions because they have the hardy hood to set us at
defiance upon my word.
If we are to run after America in search of reconciliation in this way,
I do not know a single act of parliament that will remain,
but despite having settle that north concluded this speech by saying he wanted
to be quote,
thought what I really am to the best of my conviction,
a friend to trade a friend to America.
Okay.
Is that a lot of stuff bound up in that statement,
but you can really see him processing through what's happening versus what he
assumes about the workings of the imperial system.
It's a complicated situation to north and the British as well as to the
colonies.
So in the end,
thinking about all of this and thinking,
well,
I need to leave some kind of tax in place to prove parliamentary supremacy.
He decides to leave the t techs in effect.
And the logic behind that is of all the tax items,
this was the most profitable to England and it couldn't be manufactured in the
colonies,
so we would have to be imported.
Plus it was kind of central to socializing and everybody drank tea.
That was the thing to do.
It's to drink tea with great ceremony among some people to have tea cups and
teaspoons.
So north just assumed on a whole bunch of levels,
can't be easily boycotted.
They really like tea and those colonies just like us here,
it makes us a reasonable amount of money.
That's the thing that'll stay.
Now when I was writing this lecture I was thinking about that.
I'm thinking about tea and tea ceremonies and the drinking of tea and it,
I mean I feel that we all have in our mind a sense of that being the case in
England.
Um,
but it was no less the case in the colonies.
And when I was,
I guess when I was researching my first book,
I came across a story,
I'm going to mention it now only because it relates to the tea ceremony.
And this is my opportunity to tell the story.
They will be random moments when I just have to tell a story.
Cause you guys are like hostages and he's like,
I just say whatever I want.
And I get to tell random stories,
but this actually does demonstrate the sort of ritual of tea drinking
everywhere.
So the whole tea ceremony was important in the colonies.
I came across this account from a foreign observer actually from France and he
shows up in the colonies and he says in a letter to a friend that he'd never
quite seen anything like the colonial obsession with serving tea.
And he describes this visit that he paid to a woman,
um,
and he said that he will take a sip and then she would immediately refill the
cup so he couldn't figure out how to empty the cup.
Basically he doesn't want any more tea and he can't figure out how to make it
stop coming.
Yeah,
dig a little more fast.
Maybe she'll end.
He kept basically trying out one thing after another and she kept refilling the
cup and then he felt compelled to drink because it was the proper thing to do
was to eat or drink what he was served.
He didn't know that the code and the tea ceremony to stop t from being poured
with to place your teaspoon across the top of your cup.
Right.
He didn't think about that.
So at one point he's desperate because he just can't deal with anymore d so she
pours more Teen Cup and when she turned away,
he actually swallowed everything in a cup and a gulp and then put the cup in his
pocket.
Like she's not gonna notice like,
Oh,
you ate the cup
and he doesn't say what happened,
you know,
he just describes putting it in his pocket like they are now.
I settled back,
you know,
great thinking
there was serious about it.
Tea Ceremonies.
Okay.
Um,
so with full knowledge of the,
the cultural importance of t and the colonies,
um,
north left the tea in effect,
hoping that a slight concession on the part of England maybe would chip away at
colonial unity.
Right.
Maybe some colonists would be convinced to stop resisting.
Maybe non importation would thus collapse and eventually not importation does
collapse.
It kind of dribbles to a close 17,
70 1771.
And as with the stamp act,
both the colonies and the British administration assumed that they had emerged
from this victorious,
right?
The colonies think ha we got most of those offensive acts repealed.
Parliament thinks,
well we are still maintaining our sovereignty.
So our point stands firm.
Now of course,
this did nothing to resolve the conflict about the precise nature of
sovereignty,
the precise nature of the imperial system and the precise power of parliament
over the colonies
at about this time.
However,
Lord north,
once again thinking about the colonies attempting reform,
he's struggling.
Clearly you have to feel,
I just feel bad for a prime minister at this moment of massive confusion in the
colonies.
He's trying to figure out some way to get colonial affairs in control.
So at this point he figures maybe one way to sort of calm things down is to
focus on Massachusetts,
right?
Massachusetts is the pesky colony.
Bad things happen in Massachusetts.
So he says maybe one way to resolve things is to make a few little tweaks in
their political system.
So he decides that Henceforth Superior Court judges will be paid by tax revenue
collected by the crown from the colonies,
which means in effect,
Superior Court judges are not going to be paid by colonial legislature.
Is there going to be paid by the crown?
Okay.
So certainly to some people in Massachusetts,
the seemed like it's a way to make judges accountable to British authorities and
not to colonists.
And in a sense that was part of what north was trying to do here.
But unfortunately,
at about the same time,
in June of 1772,
there was a crisis in Rhode Island,
um,
a British ship,
the gas bay,
which was used in Rhode Island to prevent smuggling ran aground in Rhode Island.
And that night colonist swarmed aboard.
It forced the crew off and burned it to the ground.
Okay.
That's kind of a strong anti British,
like we hate that you're stopping smuggling act.
So the crown responded by creating a commission of inquiry to investigate the
matter.
And ultimately this committee decides it's going to let this slide,
which is a major concession because burning one of his majesty's ships is a
serious matter,
right?
It's not like a minor crime even.
So Collin is just took offense at the existence of the commission,
which seem to interfere with the internal affairs of a colony.
And even worse,
this gets back to something that people have been upset about in the colonies
before the commission would have sent the people who are going to be tried to
England for their trials.
Right?
So,
and this also feels like a threat to self rule.
So you have these sorts of things going on.
Their individual acts,
they're not connected,
but they're in the eyes of many Collin is not good things.
Samuel Adams,
brilliant propagandists than he is decides there has to be an immediate response
to these new encroachments on colonial rights.
And it needs to not just be in Boston.
There needs to be a widespread interstate protest to what's happening and to the
implications of what's happening.
So in November of 1772 building on the whole model of the non importation
associations,
he suggests in the Boston town meeting that a committee of correspondence be
formed in Boston to communicate the current state of affairs in Boston to the
rest of the colony end quote to the world,
right?
He's ambitious,
Samuel Adams,
and to solicit responses.
So a committee of correspondence of roughly 21 men is created with the purpose
as stated in the Boston town meeting of stating quote the rights of the
colonists and of this province in particular as men and Christians and as
subjects,
which is an interesting trio as men,
as Christians and as subjects and to communicate and publish the same to the
several towns and to the world as the sense of this town with the infringements
and violations there of that have been or from time to time may be made right.
Infringements that have been made or maybe made right.
So he's even,
something else is going to happen.
And if it is,
we've got a committee of correspondence in place.
So by the end of November of 1772,
the committee had produced an open letter to all of the towns in Massachusetts
urging them quote not to dos or sit supine,
Lee in different on the brink of destruction that Samuel Adams,
it's really a master at the strong words.
Um,
and to create their own committees of correspondence.
And more than half of the towns in Massachusetts responded encouraging more
widespread participation in the controversy than before.
More widespread willingness to act alongside the normal political system to
protest what people saw as an unconstitutional act.
And there were more than 80 of these local committees of correspondence created
within just a few months.
One observer called these committees,
quote the foulest subtlest and most venomous serpent ever issued from the egg of
sedition.
And you can kind of see this person's fears,
right?
This is the person who sees what he perceives to be as organized resistance to
the British government sort of bubbling up in Massachusetts and this sort of
bubbling committees or committees of correspondence.
They're going to be spreading sedition according to this person throughout the
colonies and possibly to the world.
And this person had a right to be suspicious because organized resistance is
partly what these committees are all about.
So this unfolding of events in Massachusetts led radicals elsewhere to do what
Massachusetts had done and create their own committees of correspondence for
communication within colonies and between the colonies.
So within roughly a year,
by very,
very early in 1774,
there were committees of correspondence and almost every colony
and these committees did a number of things.
They strengthened ties between radical colonies like Massachusetts and less
active or less radical colonies.
And they created a way for radical minded people in different colonies to
interact with each other.
So clearly these committees of correspondence,
just like the non importation associations are an important stepping stone in
the growing sense of colonial unity.
Now,
it was at this moment that Lord north past the tea act,
um,
it actually had less to do with the colonies then it had to do with a miserably
timed necessity.
North was trying to save the east India tea company from collapse the tea act of
1773 removed import duties on east India tea,
which basically made British teach cheaper than Dutch tea in the hope that this
would inspire colonist to purchase British tea.
Okay,
so you would think,
and certainly you can understand why Lord North would think that this would make
the colonists happy because he is lowering duties on t the east India company
hopefully as he's thinking would be solvent,
maybe the towns than to act my little t tags left in place.
There is going to matter less because I've just lowered duties on some tea so
maybe now the colonists we'll pay the t tax parliament will obviously have the
right to tax the colonies in their eyes and maybe this will actually quiet
things a little,
but once again the British government misjudge the colonial reaction.
Again,
showing how you have different evolving mindsets here and they're not
necessarily either one understanding what's happening in the other case.
So if the colon is not surprisingly had their own interpretation of the act,
they actually felt that the act was granting a monopoly to the east India tea
company in forcing the control of the British government over what they felt
like was supposed to be free trade.
So maybe in the future the British would begin to control the importation of
other goods as well.
Okay.
So somewhat paradoxically by the duty on English tea north helped fuel colonial
fears that there was a plot in England against colonial rights,
which inspired the colonist to imagine the worst immediately when a suspicious
act was passed.
So,
oh,
this must be part of that plot.
This TX,
yes,
he may seem to be lowering the duty on Auntie,
but there must be another motive.
Ah,
they must be trying to control our trade.
You could sort of see on both sides how the logic makes sense.
You can also see how this is a problem.
As with the stamp act,
colonist responded by pinpointing the people who would be distributing the t,
right?
So first he didn't want to be a stamp agent.
Now you don't want to be a person selling tea.
So they pinpointed the merchants who were selling tea and they pressured them
not to sell it,
and broadsides were posted in public places to inform and involve the populace
saying things like friends,
brethren,
countrymen,
that worst of plagues,
the detested t shipped for this port by the east India company is now arrived in
this harbor,
the hour of destruction or manly opposition to the machinations of tyranny.
Stare you in the face.
It's like big drama.
You know,
these are not people who do things halfway destruction staring you in the face.
Tyranny,
manly,
opposition.
So when ships loaded with t began arriving in major colonial ports,
obviously things become more heated in some cities.
The t was just unloaded and then locked up in a warehouse and left.
They're not sold in Philadelphia and New York.
They actually kept these ships with tea on them out,
away from the harbor so that they just never came in close to shore.
However,
in Boston,
Governor Hutchinson decided to force the issue in his mind as a means of
protecting British sovereignty in the colonies.
So Hutchinson ordered the ta ships to be unloaded.
Okay.
So we have an eye witness account of someone who heard the response to that
announcement.
Who heard what happened when it was people heard that Hutchinson was going to
ask for the to be unloaded and it was at a Boston town meeting December 16th,
1773.
Um,
basically people knew that there was this t bearing ship in the harbor and they
knew that on December 16th in the evening,
the captain of that ship was going to go to the town meeting and tell the town
meeting Samuel Adams who was chairing the meeting,
what was going to happen with the T.
People knew that.
And thus there was an enormous crowd gathered outside of the old south church
where the meeting was being held to see what would happen.
Right.
So everyone knows this is like the stare down.
Okay,
what's going to happen is the t coming off the boats and if the [inaudible]
coming off the boats,
what happens next?
Big crowd.
And here's what this eyewitness heard as the crowd learned that Hutchinson was
insisting on the unloading of the tea.
So this eye witness,
he's at home drinking tea.
When he said,
I heard such prodigious shouts that induced me while drinking tea at home to go
out and know the cause of it.
The meeting house was so crowded,
I could get no farther than the porch you'd have fought.
The inhabitants of the infernal regions had broke loose from my part.
I went contentedly home and finished my team.
What's going on?
I got to go finish my day.
But with soon informed what was going forward.
Right as soon told,
like they're going to unload the tea but still not crediting it without ocular
demonstrations.
Okay.
18th Century.
I wanted to see it for myself,
but not crediting it without ocular demonstrations I went to watch.
Okay.
So our eye witness goes off to get ocular demonstrations of the unloading of the
tea.
Um,
but what he ends up watching is an assemblage of somewhere between 30 and 60 men
disguised as Indians,
a board,
three ships on Griffin's wharf.
And these men basically worked on those shifts for several hours and through 342
chests of tea over the side.
A huge number of people watched from the docks.
And as I mentioned before,
when I was talking about the stamp act riots and popular demonstrations were
kind of a regular part of the system in the colonies.
Riots were not normally chaotic moments of violence and disorder unless you were
shingle by shingle picking apart the house of the stamp agent for example.
Um,
but usually they were almost ritualized demonstrations of protest.
So what we have here is not a wild riot on these ships.
Protesters were so careful not to do anything other than make their point not to
do anything other than destroyed t that allegedly they brought a locksmith with
them to open lots or repair locks that were broken.
I mean,
these are people who understand property rights,
right?
We value property.
We don't want to break your locks.
I mean,
they're not actually out to get the ship owners.
They just want the tea.
So they actually were very orderly about the way in which they went to destroy
the team.
So to give us a sense of what happened,
I'm going to use an account by another man.
His name is George Hughes.
He actually helped destroy the tea.
So he's one of the people throwing chests of tea over the side.
And in his account he says that back at the old south church,
the announcement that Hutchinson was going to order the unloading of the t led
to quote a general Hassan for Griffin's wharf that has ah,
is like an 18th century who ray,
you know,
off to Griffin's war.
So these guys were like,
you're going to unload the tea,
we're there and something bad is gonna happen.
So Hughes a participant in what would come to be known but not until well into
the 19th century as the Boston tea party continues his account,
he says it was now evening.
And I immediately dress myself in the costume of an Indian equipped with a small
hatchet with which,
and the club after having painted my face and hands with coal dust in the shop
have a blacksmith I repaired to Griffin's wharf where the ships lay that
contained the tea.
And he uses order to go to the captain and demand of him the keys to the hatches
because they don't want to damage the ship and it doesn't candles so they can
see what they're doing.
I mean there've been very sort of polite here.
The captain probably replied and delivered the articles but requested me at the
same time to do no damage to the ship or rigging.
So these Indians cut and split the teacher tests with their Tomahawks and threw
them overboard.
There were some people who tried to climb on board the ship to scoop up t to
take back home with them.
This was not a wise thing to do because they were caught and their hats and wigs
were dumped in the water with the tea and they were kicked away.
Like literally the crowds are just kicked them away from the ships on the wharf.
So heels concludes his account by saying we then quietly retired to our several
places of residence without having any conversation with each other or taking
any measures to discover who we are,
our associates,
right.
Cause they're all disguised.
Nor do I recollect of our having had the knowledge of the name of a single
individual concerned.
And the affair there appeared to be an understanding that each individual should
volunteer his services,
keep his own secret and risk the consequences for himself.
No disorder took place during that transaction.
And it was observed at that time that the stillest night ensued that Boston had
enjoyed for many months.
So not wild abandoned.
It's a pretty controlled riot.
However,
Lord North was dumbfounded because he really thought he had given the colonies
what he called a relief instead of an oppression.
And he assumed that only what he called quote New England fanatics would've
rebelled against his measure.
So this event,
this,
this tea event in Boston is proved to him that the issue no longer is one of
taxation,
but now this appears to him to be more about whether Britain had any authority
over quote the Hottie American Republicans at all.
And this is an actual transcription of part of the parliamentary debate of what
to do after this was discovered.
North said,
the Americans have tarred and feathered your subjects plundered,
your merchants burnt.
Your ships denied all obedience to your laws and authority.
Yet so Clement and so long for bearing has our conduct bin.
That is,
it is incumbent on us now to take a different course.
Whatever may be the consequence,
we must risk something if we do not.
All is over and another member of parliament said he thought quote,
the town of Boston ought to be knocked about their ears and destroyed.
Okay,
I am of opinion.
You will never meet with that proper obedience to the laws of this country until
you have destroyed that nest of locusts.
Okay.
Boston is not popular in parliament.
Another member said,
we're moving back into arrogant British quotation territory.
Lord north could not do a better thing than to put an end to their town
meetings.
I would not have a man of a mercantile cast every day collecting him so
themselves together and debating about political matters.
I would have them follow their occupations as merchants and not consider
themselves as ministers of that country.
You have sir?
No government,
no governor.
The whole,
or the proceedings of a tumultuous and riotous rabble who aught,
if they had the least prudence to follow their mercantile employment and not
trouble themselves with politics and government,
which they do not understand.
Okay.
Go back to your regular jobs,
guys like don't miss and government.
It's like,
what,
what are they doing?
Why are they doing this?
They're merchants.
They're not politicians.
And look what they're doing.
They're messing up the imperial system.
Okay.
The result of that kind of sentiment would be the passage of four acts that
Americans termed the intolerable act passed in parliament in the spring of 1774.
Um,
and I'm so on the cusp of running out of time.
I think what I will do is pause there since we're just about out of time for
class.
Um,
we will continue,
we will add the details of the intolerable acts and then move into the logic of
resistance,
which is going to look at how this is adding up to an ongoing logic in the
colonial mindset.
How's that there?